hormones are the literal signaling  molecules that will communicate amongst  your organ systems that give signals of  what to do for your health there's three  main classes of hormones or signaling  molecules most people are familiar with  the first two classes those are your  sterol hormones or your cholesterol  based for example testosterone estrogens  are another one of those for example  estradiol you also have peptide hormones  so growth hormone is an example insulin  is another example of a life-saving  peptide and then you also have hormones  that are based just on amino acids for  example thyroid hormone is based on  tyrosine there's many things called  feedback inhibition or feedback  mechanisms that can be positive or  negative and hormones can act on these  to try to preserve your health but when  it's in a dysregulated state pathology  can occur so they're just the signaling  molecules that control all of your  health